Speaker 1: Hey, this is just the
best. This is another reminder
of how all of these supposed principles of
the modern Republican right are meaningless
to. Them. They only care about what is good for
me right now. As you might remember, when we
were getting closer to the 2020 election, it was
Republicans united that mail in ballots are bad.
Mail in ballots help Democrats mail in ballots
allow Democrats to commit fraud. And on and
on and on. And in the immediate aftermath of
the 2020 election, it was Republicans saying,
we've got to stop the count or start the count or
count these correctly or that. But the point was
the mail in ballots are bad for democracy. They
could be criminal, they are fraudulent, and
they just must be stopped because that's that's
what the Democrats do. Well, now they are still
counting ballots in the Pennsylvania Republican
Senate primary. This was the race we covered live
last Tuesday and which on Wednesday, I told
you, Mehmet Oz is just slightly ahead of Dave
McCormick, but they're still counting ballots.
Well, now, Democrat I'm sorry, Republicans,
candidates and the parties are arguing among
themselves. Count the mail in ballots. Don't
count them. Include these. Throw these out because
they don't have a date on them. They don't care
about the principles. All they care about is what
helps me. Right now, there's an article from the
New York Times. McCormick sues to count undated
mail in ballots trailing Oz in Pennsylvania
Senate Race. Wait, wait a second. Hold on. So. In
2020. The problem was any irregular ballot like it
doesn't have a date on it or whatever the case may
be, you've got to throw it out. That's bad stuff.
Now, the undated mail in ballots are believed to
be likely good for Dave McCormick and not so good
for. Oh, now we've got to sue. We'd better count
those mail in ballots, even if they don't have a
date. As irregular as it is for the ballot to not
have a date written in, we must make sure that the
will of the voter is represented and that the vote
is counted. But you guys were just against that.
David McCormick is trying to close the gap against
Mehmet Oz in the undecided Republican primary
contest. In this is Neil Vigdor in The New York
Times. In a lawsuit filed Monday in Pennsylvania,
the Republican Senate candidate David McCormick
demanded that undated mail in ballots should
be counted in his primary race against celebrity
physician Mehmet Oz, whom he trailed by less than
a thousand votes. McCormick asked the court of
Pennsylvania to allow election officials in all 67
counties to accept mail in ballots from voters who
turned them in by the May 17 deadline but didn't
write the date on the outer return envelopes.
That step is required by law, one that Republicans
have fought to preserve. It's been Republican
Republicans in Pennsylvania and other states
who have argued for 2020. If there is no date
written on the outside, you put that in the trash,
you cover it in rocket fuel and you burn it.
We don't count it. But now all of a sudden,
McCormick wants it counted. Okay, arguing the
ballots were indisputably submitted on time.
They were date stamped upon receipt and
no fraud or irregularity has been alleged.
Hmm. In the McCormick campaign's
lawsuit, Mr. Hicks, who is this lawyer,
took the opposite view of mail in ballots, saying
the election boards in Allegheny County in western
Pennsylvania and Blair County have balked at
counting the undated ballots. Those counties,
he said, were delaying taking action until
after Tuesday, when they are required to report
unofficial results to the state. The board's
refusal to count the ballots at issue violates
the protections of the right to vote. Under
the Federal Civil Rights Act and Pennsylvania
Constitution. Whoa. That's that's pretty serious.
Now, you might remember that the very same lawyer
was part of a group of lawyers that Trump hired
to challenge mail in ballots in the 2020 election.
The same lawyer now saying count all the
ballots was part of a group of lawyers saying
don't count them in November of 2020 when
he worked for Donald Trump. As a reminder,
here is Dave McCormick on election night
saying, hey, you know what? We've still
got mail in ballots coming. We might still be
able to win this thing. Now, we're going to get.
Speaker 2: We're going to win this campaign.
Unidentified: We're going to win this campaign.
And and tomorrow, right.
Speaker 2: Now, we have tens of.
Speaker 3: Thousands of mail
in ballots that have not been.
Speaker 1: Counted. Right.
Speaker 2: That are going to need
to be counted beginning tomorrow.
And. And so that's unfortunate.
We're not going to have resolution tonight.
Speaker 1: Okay. So now mail in ballots are good.
What is the takeaway? The takeaway? These people
are pathetic. They don't really have principles.
It's whatever is good for me, whatever is good
for me is the principle. We'll see ultimately
who wins this one. But just remember this. Just
remember this when they start making all sorts of
claims about mail in ballots in November. Monday,
Memorial Day, we're doing our one day membership
special. Make sure you're on my newsletter at
David Pakman dot com. If you are, you'll be
notified Monday morning of how to take advantage
of this great one day membership discount.